captain tom moore stepped up
nobody could have imagined that when we
started
it would ever get to how it turned out
his sponsored walk the most unexpected
beacon of hope
a man with remarkable spirit whose death
has brought the highest of tributes
captain sir tom moore was a hero in the
truest sense of the word
in the dark days of the second world war
he fought for freedom
and in the face of this country's
deepest post-war crisis
he united us all the queen
sent a private message to his family
recognizing the inspiration he provided
for the whole nation
and others around the world
with flags flown at half-mast over
downing street
and the arches over wembley and the
blackpool tower lit up
it was a fitting farewell
the army veteran had aimed to complete a
hundred laps of his garden before his
100th birthday
to raise a thousand pounds for the nhs
he eventually raised more than 32
million
who would ever thought that something
like this would happen
from a little family probably joke for
doing a thousand pounds it got into this
enormous sub and it really is an
enormous sum
more than a hundred thousand people sent
him a birthday card
as the raf paid their own tribute to
mark his centenary
and say thanks to this military man from
yorkshire who continued to serve his
country
in the most remarkable ways they say
never meet with heroes but in this case
you know he exceeds expectations he's
just he was so easy to host
he was so good with people you know he
obviously had a good time he enjoyed
being in the military environment
and we just loved having him around but
this is what he described as the most
special of days
four months ago i was just tom moore
now i'm sir tom moore i mean
no one could ever believed that in that
time
this would happen to me and i'm
absolutely
i've been really honored that this
should happen
cementing his celebrity status and
number one single with michael
ball making him the oldest person to top
the charts
[Applause]
[Music]
always showing a cheeky optimism as
demands for his time
didn't die down yeah it doesn't have to
be word perfect
it does not doesn't need it doesn't need
to be word perfect well that's not good
we like it perfect
captain sir tom was admitted to bedford
hospital with coronavirus at the end of
january
he'd been receiving treatment for
pneumonia before that
which meant he hadn't been vaccinated
against covert 19.
displaying the resilience of the wartime
generation
he inspired this generation
the sun will shine and will never
walk alone and just do this i believe
that to be true
a life we can celebrate for the light
that he brought
into so many lives rhiannon mills
sky news